what's the role of violence in this
operation I am extreme uh you know it
used to be that there were rules as you
say like
you know don't go after kids don't go
after women but all those things are
gone now you know they had been gone for
decades I think
uh the escalation of violence you know
you kill one of mine I'll kill four of
yours you kill four of mine I'll go
after your family because you were in
hiding
um there's stories of uh high-level
cartel people getting their you know
sons and and daughters you know murdered
mutilated uh and revenge killings so I
think it's uh it's at a point where it's
spiraled a lot of semblance of a rule
set as far as who can get exposed to
some of this violence those highly
produced Isis videos
where they show torture and executions
uh According to some of the sources that
I've talked to here in the United States
that we're looking at that phenomenon
they said that it seems to be that that
was influenced by some of the Narco Blog
videos that that were coming out of
Mexico early in the early 2000s
basically that some of these groups were
the first ones that got wind of the fact
that you can
export Terror or the horror that an
execution has through social media
way back when Facebook was a bit more a
bit more of a Wildland area you could
see these in news feeds uh videos of
executions tortures and stuff like that
coming out of Mexico on Facebook way
back when wow this was a different time
um the people who criticize social media
and the moderation is a tough it's a
tough job because the brutal world out
there I mean I remember seeing some of
these Isis videos on on on Facebook way
back when and they you know they cracked
down all that but uh one that's kind of
clear and I'll see I'm not gonna say
where to find it but people out there
might have seen it because some of these
videos get shared through WhatsApp
groups and
chat groups out there uh one of the ones
that caught my attention way back when
was a guy getting two guys getting
executed by a chainsaw
um and
you know people can kind of
thing imagine what that would be like
but uh this is produced on purpose like
this video it's a cartel group caught
two rival cartel members and a way to
send a message to those of their rival
cartel is to basically execute these
people in front of a camera uh I mean
you can't get to your Rivals but you can
you can make them see what they're doing
or at least make their people look at
what happens if you you know invade
their territory
just an escalation of brutality in the
violence as well I mean and at least a
terror and then sort of mass
communication of Terror yeah I mean you
you have videos of some of these people
engaging in cannibalism in front of a
video to see how brutal they are or
uh people taking out somebody's heart
while they're alive you know and filming
it and you know it used to be social
media as a whole you'll see some of
these videos they would they would get
put down and and for in a few days
but now there's telegram groups uh
there's uh you know there's Live Leaks
there's a bunch of other uh sites out
there that kind of disperse some of
these videos and
it's basically a bulletin board for them
as far as you know hey you got into my
territory well this is what's going to
happen to you